all right in this series of videos we're
going to create a web application from
scratch using only the Java programming
language no HTML no JavaScript at all
yeah we will have to touch a little bit
of XML and maybe configuration files but
it's super easy to understand and so
here's the plan so first we are going to
create a new project from scratch again
then we're going to implement
authentication and authorization using
Spring Security
we are going to implement a curved view
that is a create read update and delete
with database connectivity we are going
to then add a form that has
collaborative features and it's going to
be really really interesting and we're
going to add a view to show a report
that you can export to for example PDF
or common separated values and many
other formats actually
and then the icing on the cake for this
project is to add cookie consent
dialogue and that's very very easy to do
with writing so let's start with the
first step setting up the project
right
[Music]
all right so I'm going to use
Scientology idea for this project and
let's just go ahead and create a new one
using the spring initializer I'm going
to leave all these as as it is I'm just
going to change here to Java 17.
next we are going to use spring boot Dev
tools lumbug so that we don't have to
code getter letters and all that
we're going to use Spring Security here
of course we are going to use my
favorite
web framework for Java which is vading
and we are going to use spring data the
APA
and let's use also my favorite database
mariadb
finish and
let me show you what we have
here by default
if we have a bunch of files here that we
are not interested in uh but the
important part is that you get the
source here
with just one Java class
which has a public static wall domain
this is kind of the entry point of a
Java standard Java application and in
this case it's a spring boot application
but before we continue
let me add some other dependencies that
I need for this product so I'm going to
go to value.com
directory which is a place where you can
find third party
components for wedding
and I promised I would create a crowd
view right and so there is a
there's a component that allows you to
do that very very easily
crud UI add-on which I created
some years ago
so let's copy first the repository the
maven repository and let's add it and
then think there is a repositories
section
so we need to add that here
and let's add the repository there now
let's copy the dependency I'm gonna add
it just right after voting spring boot
starter
what else do we need to do here
I think that's it so we also need
um and add on to create to easily create
reports later in a later video so let's
copy the dependency and added here we
need to copy the repository because it's
the same but we are going to also use
the collaboration engine from vadin wish
I think I can find here
let's copy this
added another thing I want to do is to
use maybe the latest version of writing
so let's check that
here releases
and so it's a 21
0 6
as of today
let me click over here and also maybe
the collaboration engine let's use the
latest version
here it is
there we go we refresh the maven project
so that the ID knows which dependencies
it should use and I think this should be
ready
okay
now let's configure a couple of things
here so in the application.properties
file we need to configure the database
connection
so that would be spring dot data source
data source URL and okay so for the URL
let's create a new connection here
inside my
IDE
a
dibim
and I have one server
running already
I think my user is rude let's use root
don't do this in production of course
and
I think my password is password
um succeeded all right so yeah it's
working
apply
let's copy this
URL and that's what we are going to use
uh right here now maybe I should create
a
schema here so let's create a new schema
which is kind of a database inside
mariadb let's call these books
okay
so we should have it there and there are
no tables but jpa is going to create
that
slash books we need to specify the name
of the database in the connection URL
now let's go ahead and use uh or
configure the username
and the password
as word
and another thing that I'd like to do is
to configure a ddl Hodo from
hibernate to
let's use update here so it creates the
databases or the objects in the in the
database
another thing I want to do is avoiding a
specific value in white listed packages
it's going to be uh useful Forum or or
make so at the completion much much
quicker
so we're going to add this package over
here com example demo
and this could be a list of packages
separated by a comma
or by comments
so we need to add also common dividing
because we need anything that comes from
those packages anything that is related
to that and we should add it here or the
dividing because there are add-ons and
if you add you have your own or add-ons
and you add here more packages uh always
remember to do that I hope I didn't make
any mistakes here but I think we'll get
an error if I if I don't do this
correctly so let's double check com
example demo
com.org.body and I think that should be
all right I guess we have configured the
the project now all right so now that we
have the application ready and
configured we can create a backend so
we're going to add an entity a
repository and a service class that the
UI can use to retrieve data to write
data to update data whatever it needs to
do with the database
thank you
okay so we need two packages here let's
create one for the back end
and we will need another one
for layer for the UI just so you get the
idea of what's the structure what the
structure of the project is and let's
install it by creating a new Java class
called book
and books is going to be
um
an entity or a Java object that
encapsulates
uh you guessed it information about
books private
long ID private string title
private let's add maybe a local date
for
published when the book was published
private let's create an integer
for the rating of this book
how good the book is
I think that should be it and since we
are using
um lumbug I can just add data here maybe
actually we need an all or no arcs
Constructor and let's be explicit here
all Eric's constructure and also the
equals and hash code I really want it to
be only on
uh on the ID so I'm going to include the
ID
and we now have a polio right
plain old Java object that we can map to
a table in the database so let's use jpa
for that entity
and because it's an empty it needs an ID
and we are going to generate this value
using the strategy identity so it's
going to have one two three four five
and so forth for the IDS
we don't need to specify the IDS now
um I guess that's it now we have
everything so just to to show you what
what we have actually is all the Setters
and Getters and we have uh two
Constructors
and equals and hash code using the ID
field here okay very good we have that
class ready now let's create a new book
report story
this is very easy to do repository this
is actually optional but I like to be
explicit there and it's not a class it's
an interface
we're gonna extend
jpa Repository
from
spring data
and it's a repository of books which
have
ideas of type long and just with that we
have now a bunch of very useful methods
to interact with the database like count
delete find all save and so forth
we don't need to implement this again
we can just inject
instances of this type and the spring
spring framework is going to create them
automatically for us and spring data is
going to implement the class or the
interface all right so we have the the
report story but it would be good to
have also a book service that
the UI can use and here I do need to
specify service
and let's let's extend one of the
classes that are provided
um by the crude UI are done which is
correct listener and it's a correct
listener off
books you'll see uh why later in the
video but this also allows me to quickly
implement
these methods over here so first to
follow these are
books so I'm gonna
just change this to book
and we probably need
it's not extends it's actually
implements it's an interface I can show
you the interface here
very simple one
but we need we probably need the uh
The Book Repository right let's call
this Repository
and let's use the number here to have
um required Arts Constructors we have I
can show you that too we have this
Constructor we don't have to implement
it and spring is going to inject
an instance
of these type so this is not null
anymore and we can use it repository dot
find all
repository dot save
book and in fact
update is exactly the same
and here repository dot delete book
and I guess that's about it we have the
service class implemented and in fact we
have the whole backend implemented now
so this is step three of the tutorial
where we are going to implement
authentication and authorization using
Spring Security so this means that
creating a login screen
uh with the username and password and
then securing views so that all the
users with the determined role can
access these views all right so let's
just jump into the code
[Music]
so let's configure a Spring Security
here and
since 1921 I believe there is a helper
class that allows us to configure that
very very easily and it's called batting
web security configure adapter so we
have to extend that class
and we need to override we need to
override a couple of things here so the
first one is configure
with the HTTP security object here
and what we're going to do here is set a
login view that we're going to create in
a moment so let's call that
loggingview.class it doesn't exist but
we're going to create it in a moment
then we need to override also
uh you the user
um user Detail Service bin method to
create some users so we can play with
something right and this is the bin so I
need to
mark it as a bin here and instead of
returning this we're going to return a
new in memory user details manager
uh that receives
for example
an array of user details objects and one
way to create those is let me format
this like that is by using the user
class over here and then configure this
for example with username
let's create one for me Alejandro
password is going to be password and
this is going to be encrypted or it's
going to use an encoder so we're gonna
use one that it's no operation
uh this is the easiest way to do it just
to specify this here don't do that at
home or at least not in production
use a proper encoder password encoder
[Music]
um
then we can also specify the list of
roles we're gonna use only one role in
this example application admin
and after that we can just build the
object so this is the Builder pattern
and we can create another one
separated by a comma here because it's
an array of objects for let's say
Maria
and you know what let's change this only
to the letter P so it's easier to type
later when I'm using the app in the
browser
um okay so we have configured the
um
web security using Spring Security now
we just need to create this class and it
is extremely extremely simple let's
create this in the UI package because
it's a
a view so it's going to go here there it
is
this of course is a valid view so it
requires a route
for example logging it could be anything
really at least so that we go to slash
logging and then we'll see this this
view that we are going to implement here
and here's the first trick of this
tutorial it's very easy to implement
these actually uh by extending
um
composite
of
login
overlay
and then here in the Constructor
what we can do
is uh
let me say first this related problem
here
where it's going on
maybe it requires the import
it's not that
let's read the message how can I read
the message
oh yeah I forgot something here so I
wasn't paying attention to the
parameters I need to pass the HTTP
object as well all right now it's
compiling very good and back to the
login view all we need to do here is get
the content which is this login overlay
it's going to return an object of that
type and then set opened
true because it's an overlay right it's
going to be on top of the screen
so we need to open it and then set
action
logging so it's going to use slash login
using the post
um
using post instead of of get so it's not
going going to clash with this
right
and let's bring security is going to
manage that authentication for us we
really don't need to do anything else
here it's uh
very little code and we get a logging
view
um
now
we probably need a couple of views to
check that the authentication and
authorization is working so let's create
first a home View
route
empty so slash empty nothing
because if it's a home view so it makes
sense vertical layout
let's use vertically out here
and oops where did it go let me see uh
here it is
a Constructor
where we are gonna simply for now let's
just add a new H1 component so a new
title
home View
let's format this like that so we can
add more things is here later right
um and we need to say hey this is for
everybody you need to have a user
registered in this you need to be
Alejandro or Maria which are the users
we created in order to see this view so
we mark this with Anonymous aloud
and now we can check that part and let's
create another view
admin View
route
slash admin
again extends vertical
layout
and let's create
something similar here so add
let's add a new H1
admin View
we need to specify the the rows so roles
allowed from this package
admin because all uppercuts because
that's what we use in the configuration
here for these two users
all right
very good so we have I guess something
we can
try the first time you uh if you are
following this you are trying this by
yourself the first time you run this
application takes a bit longer than
subsequent runs but uh
um it shouldn't be it shouldn't be a lot
of time though
let's see how it goes this time
uh the reason is because it has to
download all the maven dependencies
which maybe in my case I maybe I had
those already
but it also has to build
um the front end and download the
client-side dependencies so that's what
this is doing right now that's what
front-end compilation means
and once you get it ready we should be
able to see
the application here home view so it
works
but if I go to admin we should see the
login form there we go so we didn't code
this thing and it shows the login form
automatically which is so cool so let's
try with my username here the password
was just one letter login
and now I can see the admin view as well
all right so we are on step four of the
tutorial where we are going to create a
curd curd means create read update and
delete so it's going to be a view with
all these operations and this view is
going to connect to the mariadb database
to
um allow the user create new books or to
edit the books or delete the book and
and so forth so um let's jump right into
the code
foreign
[Music]
view right the one that it's uh used by
users with the role admin so it's
protected let's say by
um Spring Security and now we want to
create this script so we're gonna add it
here
crud
and that that is
created here
a new grid crud which comes from the
from the add-on crud UI and you need to
specify here the the type it's a code of
um books so that's what we'll specify
here
and believe it or or not only with that
we have the user interface Forum crud
view so let's check that out
there we go so we have
uh the options to add a new book we have
a grid or a table it's called grid
invading with all the books and one
column per property in the in the
book class and we can add
new books here of course it doesn't
really work yet
it doesn't really save the item as it
says there
because it's not connected to the back
end so how can we do that
uh
that's pretty simple so we need to add
here
or be actually before that I just
noticed that we have the ID here and
maybe this is not in the best order
possible The Columns and the same for
the um
and the form so let's let's configure
that and that's very easy to do so we
can just get the grid which is a
valid component right
and we can set the columns using the
names of the properties in the domain
object or domain class which is book so
we're going to use title published and
rating
title
published rating and now it's going to
show only those columns there and for
the form to configure the form we need
to get the crud form Factory
and again set visible properties it's
going to be the same
I want to use exactly the same
so let's just copy from there to avoid
typos I hope I didn't make any typos
um
let's try that out actually before
continuing to see that
the UI looks the way we want title
published writing that's good now we
don't have the ID here and and we only
have these three Fields all right very
good so let's connect that to the back
end and the back end is
book service
let's call it service here
and
if you have a look at this
Constructors there is one that accepts a
crud form sorry
um correct listener and remember that we
did that before in the previous video
credit listener we implemented that that
means that to connect this to the
backend all we have to do is pass the
service class there
and
that should be it really so we should be
able to
save data
using this view so let's try that out
let's add my recent book practical
writing published
it's very recent I think it's just some
months ago a couple of months ago I'm
gonna give it a rating of 10 out of 10
to this book
add there we go we have it there let's
add another one
whatever published I don't know another
year just for fun
and any number here add so this is
actually in the database and we can
check that
let me just refresh this maybe
and we have The Book Table
this is an SQL client and you'll see
that inside the database
you have the two rows in this table
pretty cool huh
um yeah so that's how you can Implement
um
occurred using budding
so we are now on step five of these
tutorial where we are going to create a
form with collaborative features that is
we're going to allow the users to see
what the older users are doing in real
time that's pretty cool very easy to do
actually with writing so let's jump
right into the code
foreign
[Music]
we don't want this option here they want
to create a new book we don't want it
here in this screen we want to redirect
to another
View
and make that collaborative
how can we do that first we need to hide
this option but that's very simple if we
go to the code admin view where I have
the grid crud
we can just say crack Dot
set add operation visible false so it's
not going to show that and instead we
want to get the
current layout which is the organic kind
of the um
the component that contains all these
other components and the arrangement
there
and we're going to add a toolbar
component a toolbar component is
something shown next to these buttons
here
and we can add just a new a router link
which accepts a text first
new book
and then we can pass a component so
let's say this is new view.cloud which
doesn't exist but again we can just
create it there in the same package so
it's right here New View
let's
map this to new so it's Slash new again
instead of component we're gonna use
vertical layout
and just to quickly check that this
works let's add a title here new H1
new book
let's compile this
and we should get a link here
that goes to the new book but I want to
show you something as well so new book
it says could not navigate to New recent
access denied so that's important
security is is working
roles allowed we need to
allow the group of admin users here
right
so now I should be able to go there very
good
so we have that in place now we want to
create this form from scratch let's
create all the fields the input Fields
here private
text field
so one for the title
title private uh what else was there let
me actually refresh my memory
uh title published and writing so this
would be a date picker
for published
new date picker
and we need one
integer field
for the rating
something important is that the names of
the identifiers here match the exact
name of the properties in the book class
because we are going to do some data
binding here but for that let's add
those
um those fields to the vertical layout
but I'm not going to add them directly
there I'm going to create first a form
layout
and then we can add the title
published and rating components here
of course we need to separate these guys
from with or with a comma
we probably also need the title before
the form so let's change the position of
that and we will need a new button to
save
to save the changes
um
let's check that the UI looks
the way we want
there we go
so you have all the components here this
is a date picker
and the good thing about the
uh where is it formally out is that it's
responsive so for example if I make this
window
narrow
you see how it changes so this maybe
would be how the application would be
presented in a mobile device and you can
configure the the number of columns here
it's called steps or responsive steps
and several other things in this form
layout if you want
um Okay so
if we click this it doesn't work
so we need to First bind
the values in this
input fields to
an instance of book right
so to to the corresponding properties in
an object of this type
how to do that
actually it's pretty simple we need a
new binder here
and binder is a helper class it's not a
UI component just a helper class
and we specified the bin type which is
book
dot class
called this binder
I know we say
bind instance fields and we pass this
instance
so this means bind
their instance fields which are these
or of this class which are these
or object
to
the corresponding garage and sellers in
the book because we have it here right
in the book class or object that we are
going to create later
um
that's it so it's with this it creates
automatically create the bindings what
what it means in practice that means
that when
when we change the value here in the
browser
when we change this value
is going to be reflected in the title
property of the book
object
same with published and rating
but we need to we need to actually tell
it to do so
and
we want to do that when we click or when
the user clicks the button which is
this is a click listener I'll show you
here the Constructor it's an event
listener and it's a click event
so when we click the button we get here
I went to we need to create a new book
somehow right
because we need to save it to to the
database
so this is the book but we need to
set the values instead of using like uh
set
title and then title they'll get value
and so forth because what if the form is
huge
instead of that we use the binder
and
we can read the bin or we can write the
bin also if if valid I'm not going to go
into detail of the if valid part there
is something called there's something
called validators that we're not going
to cover here
but if it's valid just write the bin
which bin this so it's gonna because we
have already configured the connections
let's say the bindings
is going to use those connections or
bindings to write the values
here or actually here
to this instance and then then we can
use the
service which we don't have here by the
way let's get the book service injected
service Dot
save I think it's add actually
the book we are adding a new book
then we can show a notification
um
that says for example book
saved
and
if you think about it
when we are adding things here we click
the button it gets saved but this
information remains there we maybe want
to clear that correct
so we can we can set a new bin there
new book
or we can actually for example use
um
read read bin which is uh maybe it's
easier to understand because I'm using
write bin here so read bin is the
opposite so read this bin read the
values there in these properties
and set them in the corresponding fields
that we already
configured here as the bindings
so it should clear the form
if I didn't make any mistakes and should
add
um the books
to database let's see if that's
true or not
let's create
this book very original name
creative any number there
Save Book saved it's cleared let's go to
the admin View
it is there so it is in the database
very good so it actually worked
uh nothing surprising here but
what it's crazy it's how easy it is to
make it collaborative I'll show you
instead of using a binder we're gonna
use
collaboration binder
and this requires the bin type but also
a new object which is uh an object of
type user info I'm going to call it user
info so it's easier to understand it
doesn't exist yet so
let's create a new user info
and it needs a user ID at least but
we're gonna use also the name because we
want to show the name on the screen
so let's use for both we're going to use
the same it's the user name user name
that we configured it already
um
in the
Spring Security configuration right this
is the username so we have two there
but how can we get that
well we have to use security
context holder
get context yellow authentication get
principle
and
because we were using this method
this Builder we know we are created user
details objects
so that's what we need here
VAR user
details
and of course
um
let's view this let's use this user in
details we need to be explicit here of
course we need to cast that
user details dot get username
assign that to username and now we have
the object
very good so these are the changes
required by this Constructor
um
now you can see that this is deprecated
read bin is deprecated here uh
but it's clear in documentation
that you have to use set topic instead
so let's start by exploring
set topic so we need to set a topic what
is a topic it's kind of a
chat room if you wish so the people are
going to be here
this so this screen needs a name right
like this instance of this screen needs
a name so let's say this is a new book
any identifier
uh should work and then we need a
supplier of books
it can be implemented like this new book
it's of course a little bit more complex
than the standard binder because you can
imagine that it requires a bit of help
to make it collaborative
and now let's let's fix this and the
cool thing is that there's a reset
method here and we can just pass a new
instance of book
so it clears the
um
the form after we save a book
and so if it worked
if it if I didn't make any mistakes
let's go to
this screen and I probably need to open
another one here
so let's do the following
um
let's bring it like over here and this
like that
and let's use
let's use the other user here Maria
login
and it wasn't happening it was actually
new book
and you can see that as Maria is editing
this Alejandro can see what Maria is
doing so
I don't know which book I was in
but um but we can see that Maria
is doing that all right
rating
and so forth
save
the same for Maria
she would be able to see what uh any
other user
is actually doing here
so that's that's pretty impressive right
now
let's say that we want the users also to
chat here on this screen because they
need to
work together
that's also very easy to do with with
the voting collaboration engine so what
I'm going to do here is I'm going to
change the layout let's create some
space here so you get the
the idea of what I'm using or what I'm
doing so let's create a horizontal
layout here
and
what can we do let's create two vertical
layouts vertical layout
New Vertical layout
so so now we'll have like well we have
the title and then we have this
horizontal layout we're going to move
the other code later in a moment
but we have a horizontal layout that's
like having two like the screen divided
into let's go here like this screen is
going to be divided into
and on the left I want maybe
[Music]
um
the form
so I can just
move this over here
and on the left we want to implement a
chat all right I'll do that
we need two two new components here the
first one
is new
collaboration
message list
and let's see what this requires it
requires the user info that we have
already
and it requires the topic ID with also
we have new book
you should maybe uh create a constant
for that but let's leave it as is why
because it's here right so we don't need
we don't want to have it
[Music]
um
twice maybe we could introduce a typo
and it won't work
all right and the other thing you need
this collaboration message list is where
all the the messages are going to appear
and we need also a new
collaboration
message input
and that needs the list
so we need to extract these to a new
variable let's call it just message list
and since this is so clear here we can
use VAR
message list
let's compile that
I think uh that's it let's see if it
works
all right so let's use uh
Alejandro here let's use Maria here
and now they should see each others
work right
but let's say I'm creating a new book I
don't know which layer I was but let's
say it's uh e
and uh I'm editing stuff here whatever
and then Maria comes to the screen and
and sees that I'm carrying this
um
this book right
and so she says
hello Alejandro
which I reply hello Maria
and then she noticed something's wrong
I see that you are
creating
the new book
you are missing and
e in the title
so I see this and I go oh yes I'm
missing one yeah yeah
thanks
I go and fix it
save it and everybody is happy now
so that's how easy it is to add
collaboration capabilities using Biden
all right so we have arrived to step
number six which is the last step of
this tutorial where we are going to
implement A View to show a report that
you can export your PDF or comma
separated values Excel word you name it
also we are going to add a cookie
consent dialog at the very end of the
video that's super super simple to do so
make sure not to miss out on that part
foreign
[Music]
let me close all these files
a new view called report View
this is mapped to slash report
and it extends
vertical layout is fine
now we need a Constructor here
and we're gonna add some components
a new
title
actually maybe we don't need the title
here you'll see why in a moment
um but by the way what we need is to
specify the roles allowed
admin very good so now Alejandro and
Maria can access this view
um pretty good so we need to create a
report
here's how it how to do it it's also
very very simple so let's create a new
print
preview
report of books
this class comes from the
report UI component in the writing
directory
and then we can specify the columns
that we want to show there The Columns
are actually the properties the name of
the properties here so let's say we are
not interested for example in showing
the ID but only these three title
published and the rating
so we can do that title
published
and rating
this is a report
um
and uh it doesn't show any data right we
need to connect it or we need to set the
data there and for that we need the back
end which is the book service
is how we access the back end
now
um report has a method called set items
and we can pass here all the items so
service dot find all
so we want a report with all the
[Music]
um
all the books now this is failing
because
I'm returning a collection here but I
know I can return a list instead
and it should work
um
list
so now it should compile now with this
actually we should get
the report when we go to slash report
let's check that that's true and we
don't need two windows here anymore
let's go to the
report View
it's loading I guess the stuff there we
go so we have
all the books that we have created
before that come from a database and you
can configure these reports you can add
Charts you can
add sub reports you can use Jasper
reports to do it this is uh using an API
call called Dynamic Jasper
so for example
let's say we want to I don't know
[Music]
um
set the title
books
so with that and there are many other
options there with the dynamic Jasper
but I'm not gonna go through through
that
but if you now
I didn't add the title for some reason
maybe I didn't
compile I think I I actually compiled
uh let's see
there might be a bug maybe uh
maybe I should restart the application
let's try that and if if that doesn't
work then we can just continue
uh but that's same
so this is part of the Jasper Dynamic
Jasper
um
API
let's see I hope it works uh okay it's
not it's not really working for some
reason
uh this set title
method here I wonder if it's uh
fits a
um
bug or or what's going on anyway I think
I'm gonna leave it like that if you find
the solution to this please let me know
in the comments section
um
but it's how easy to add a report now
let's say we want to export this to PDF
for example
that's also very easy to do so we need
to call report dot get stream resource
and file name is going to be let's say
report or books books.pdf
then we need to specify A supplier of
books and that is
service dot find all but we can use
a method reference here so it looks
nicer
and we need to specify the format and
there are many many formats
format PDF
CSV
docx Etc so let's use PDF here
and let's call this
PDF
all right in fact we could do the same
for example for command separated values
I'm copy pasting the code here but
I guess you can imagine how how to do it
for example by iterate iterating over
all the values
right all the values have format and
then creating all the formats
if you want
or create a method that you'll just
specify the format and it creates the
rest automatically
I'm gonna I'm gonna do it like this just
um
because this is a demo I guess and here
we have we have it vertical layout so
maybe let's create a new horizontal
layout which is kind of a toolbar if you
wish with all the the buttons for
exporting the
[Music]
um
the
uh their report and here we need to
create new anchors
so this accepts
um
an abstract stream resource which is
what we got there so for example for PDF
it was called PDF this one
maybe it's not it's not it's not a good
idea to use VAR here by the way
because you don't know what it is right
probably it's better to to leave it like
that yeah much better
um and then you can specify a text so
PDF
and the same for
CSV
CSV here also
we need to separate this
um with comments
and I guess
I guess that's all you need to do to
export let's see if it works
so PDF
okay I need to
authenticate
PDF
now the browser opens the PDF but you
can of course save it
and common separated value
we can open it
outside the browser let's see if it
contains all the information
there we go all the books are there
now for some reason the title is here so
you know what I think it's happening
here it was a cash issue from the
browser because now we have it here all
right there wasn't any bug there
it's good to hear
and there you go that's how you can
create
um a report but I promise I would add
some
something special here very quickly
remember the home View
which is public
this one here and before anything else
I'm gonna actually remove any
any uh cookies here just in case I have
used this before
but here's the the uh the home View and
we want to add a cookie consent dialogue
which is required in some uh places for
example here in Europe and with that
it's so easy to do so cookie consent
compile
that's really it new cookie consent and
you get it here automatically
and it says this website uses cookies to
ensure you get the best experience a
link to more information
got it now I can use the app
and deploy it legally
just by adding one line of code